well well well then everyone welcome to
the video that both Nvidia and AMD don't
want you to watch because in my hands is
the brand new and let's be honest
terribly named graphics card from Intel
the
b580 no it's not a motherboard it's a
brand new GPU of course the big question
though is is this thing any good and I
didn't just want to flash up some
benchmarks and tell you about what it
was like I want to show you so join us
for the full ride actually if we get
this unboxed we get it put in our system
we see if there are any issues that
might happen with drivers and then
obviously we will show you the game play
like full benchmarks everything really
so you can not only see how this
performs relative to everything else but
probably more importantly you can see
whether this is actually a good card and
whether it's going to work properly in
your gaming PC so join us for everything
r a short word from this video sponsor
meet the new gigabyte g6x a crazy
powerful yet affordable gaming laptop
that oozes luxury this Mighty Machine
packs up to an RTX 4060 laptop GPU and
an Intel Core A7 13650 HX CPU allowing
you to dominate in your favorite titles
combine this with a huge 16in 165 HZ 16
by10 display with ultra slim bezels and
you're going to fall in love with PC
gaming all over again Feast your eyes on
this gorgeous laptop today with the link
down below so let me start this off by
being as open and upfront with you as
possible this obviously is a review
sample Intel haven't paid for any of
this coverage whatsoever and when they
released the previous generation the a
series let's be honest it wasn't exactly
the best launch in the world I mean we
could see that there was definitely some
potential in there but we had so many
issues actually getting the thing set up
and then there were some games where it
performed great but others where it just
didn't really work very well at all so
it was very hard to actually recommend
for anyone that wanted something that
wasn't just like a little like play
around project but fortunately Intel
over the last few months last couple of
years kept improving it to the point
where actually if you were after a
budget for any GPU it was relatively
easy to recommend it had some good like
future proof features the rage racing
performance relative to its price
actually wasn't too bad but obviously
this generation has to be different
because people in order to actually buy
this they need it to work straight away
it can't just be as I say like a project
it really has to be your gaming GPU that
you can trust for years and years to
come and the main thing really about
this is that they're comparing this
really to an RTX 4060 plus about 10%
which bearing in mind it comes in at the
time of filming around about $50 cheaper
when it comes to the RP if it's cheaper
and better and it works consistently
it'll be a no-brainer now of course just
because the RP of this comes in at 249
it doesn't mean that it actually will
I'll leave UK pricing down here as well
we don't have it the time of filming but
there is this limited edition card here
that we're obviously going to be
unboxing and using but there are going
to be some third party cards coming as
well I mean the main vendor really is
like ACA azrock and then a few kind of
lesser well-known ones and part of me I
find that slightly alarming that we're
not getting like your msis your asus's
gigabytes and things things but at the
end of the day it is a business and
you're going to have to commit like a
lot of money really to start producing
extra cards especially from a new vendor
so it's a decision that's obviously
going to be up to them and if they don't
think or they don't know the key word
they're being know that they're going to
make money from it then I guess they're
less inclined to do it and that's where
obviously your other vendors come in
that are lesser well known they see an
opportunity to sort of get ahead of the
game if it's popular people already be
buying those cards and then potentially
keep buying them going forward because
they've used them before so it's a smart
thing but if you want to grab this
limited edition one then actually I've
got to admit this is a really nice
looking GPU it's going to use a lot less
power than the previous generation as
well we have a single eight pin here and
they promised that it's going to be
whisper quiet but I don't want to say
I'll believe it when I see it but I mean
it's not going to be long till we find
out you got this classic like pass
through design and then the PCB on this
is a lot smaller as well so most of this
really is just for airf flow I mean I
get this under the overhead look so you
can see this in all of its Glory it
really is quite a thing of beauty
understated but definitely a good
looking graphics card and in terms of IO
by the way we do have three display
ports and you do have this primary
display port in the middle that I guess
is slightly higher bandwidth there's a
few extra resolution and refresh rate
options if you use this one but
interestingly enough and for a reason
I'm not entirely sure again I guess it's
bandwidth related you can do 8K 120 over
this HDMI 2.1a but not on the display
port 2.1 so there must be some kind of
restriction there but to be honest with
you this isn't really the graphics card
that's going to be aimed at like crazy
high resolutions and refresh rates at
the same time so 99% of gamers are
almost certainly going to be fine with
this and if you do want to use this for
productivity or what Intel are kind of
also touting this as surprise surprise
an AI capable graphics card they've made
a lot of improvements under the hood
then yeah I think you'd be pretty happy
with this but should we get it in our
rig oh but guys no wait look Intel I've
given you what you really want look
inside here you can actually create wait
for it your own graphics card that you
can stick on something forget about
models or super cars on your wall it's
all about a Intel graphics card oh do
get a cleaning cloth though and I will
say that yes I know I've been cancelled
for saying you can have posters of
models on your wall I was just talking
about model trains all right come on
anyway I'll stop digging myself a hole
and let's get this turned off and I will
also say whilst we're doing that the
reason we have this ominous RTX 2060
here is because I actually want to show
you the performance of this which was
kind of like the lowest powered but most
original rate racing graphics card
pricing wasn't crazy different versus as
I say our new Intel art GPU so if you're
running something like this you're what
sort of upgrades you can get and I mean
actually before we put this in our
system should we do a little size
comparison for you so here is our new
arc GPU here we have a 7900 XT here is
our 2060 here is a 3080 a 4060 a 4080
super and then last but certainly not
least let's just put this in the middle
a 4090 master I mean comparing these two
it's pretty night and day isn't it but
let's proceed to plop this inside our
rig and I am sorry that we don't have a
white card there is an azrock one on the
way that actually will perfectly match
this system but it wasn't here at the
time of filming so you're going to have
to wait for that I'm sorry right we are
in are you ready well it's not exactly
the most out there card in the world
it's just nice and tasteful which is
what you kind of expect really you've
got this light up inarc logo and it kind
of reflects actually off of the side of
the card as well certainly looks decent
I don't think anyone's going to complain
about this I mean actually it kind of
goes with our rig in a in a weird sort
of way oh there we is well okay no
issues loaded up straight away don't
forget there won't be a driver installed
technically I suppose there could be but
it's pre-released so I highly doubt it
so I mean normally this would be a
really boring bit of the video
installing the driver but do not forget
on the previous generation we had so
many issues actually getting the driver
to install in the first place and this
wasn't just a me thing this was quite
common in the industry and for people
that actually started to buy them they
were still experiencing some problems
Intel said that they fixed it which they
did but then obviously we started to see
issues in certain games they had to have
that massive update for direct X9 games
to actually run properly all of these
things I kind of want to just not be
aware of them I want to install the
driver get gaming no issues whatsoever
cuz that's what Intel have to do in
order for these to be easy to recommend
begin installation start this is kind of
the bit that we got to with that
previous generation at the launch where
it would just kind of be saying
installing and it just never would it
would be doing this infinitely Intel
haven't released anything in the last
few months hasn't worked properly so why
would I doubt
them oh oh here we go you're not going
to tell me that you're done I mean some
feedback to Intel I would like to know
that my driver has been successfully
installed please I mean I guess it's
done because the thing using most of the
CPU is Windows Defender but that is kind
of lame I honestly thought that there
wouldn't be any issues installing the
drivers whatsoever that's a bit of an
oversight but again maybe I'm just being
very dramatic here so let's restart now
and then just hope everything works
properly no way I forgot about that look
a DVI port remember those and also
remember when Nvidia gave you a USBC
Port that was really useful I don't know
why they stopped doing that old and new
on the same card but now that we are
back the big question is has the driver
taken and actually at the moment we're
still stuck at 60 HZ which is a bit
annoying I would much prefer that the
software had automatically detected the
highest resolution and the highest
refresh rate and enabled it it hasn't
which is annoying some feedback to Intel
if you could do that that' be great but
here it is 60 HZ but yes you can go to
the full 240 on this monitor this is one
of those OLED displays by the way
they're pretty phenomenal but if you do
want to see like the best OLED monitors
on the market I actually made a video
about this you can find in the top rank
corner of your screen but any 1440p
highly refresh rate monitor is going to
be a perfect pairing for this really but
the question now becomes what is the
Intel software actually going to be like
cuz again on the original versions it
wasn't great there was some
functionality improved over time but not
everything I wanted was actually there
so let's have a look oh ladies and
gentlemen this wouldn't be an arc video
without another potential issue now this
one I'm sure is probably going to get
rectified very very soon and it's not
necessarily a bug it's just a missing
feature and that is quite annoying for
me is that you can't actually record
your gameplay within the bakedin utility
that they give you maybe it's like a
separate application but I haven't been
given that and it shouldn't be it should
all be baked into the same sort of
driver software anyway so I'm actually
recording this with our good old friend
OBS with the av1 encoder that is baked
onto the GPU so it shouldn't really
affect anything and it's still fair cuz
we are using all of us obviously all the
baked encoders and all of our gameplay
testing that we do don't want to give it
a distinct Advantage but obviously there
might be a slight overhead there I mean
actually if we go into our task manager
I can show you what you mean so you can
see our GPU does have a little bit
utilization but it's actually all on
this uh video decode section here as
well so this is pretty standard and what
you would expect to see but anyway
jumping back into our Intel software
this is what it looks like you can see
that you can update your drivers here
you can choose whether you want beta
ones or not it does tell you whether you
got resizable bar on or off and it makes
it very clear which is great so CPU that
we're using is a 77008 core CPU
obviously if you're upgrading for an
older system that won't be as good as
this but this is quite a good upgrade
path so I think it's going to be
realistic anyway you can set different
profiles and things for your games so if
you want different settings to be
enabled in different titles you can do
that going down to Graphics there's not
actually that much here at the moment
I'm sure this will get fleshed out again
as the months and years go by the main
one really that you might want to turn
on is this one here called low latency
mode and there is actually going to be x
e l so XE low latency that's going to be
in certain games alongside the XS 2.0
which gives you the frame generation and
I guess just like slightly better
upscaling as well but you can do it at a
dri level as well so if the game doesn't
natively support it you can still get
some of the benefits which is good but
otherwise you can apply an FPS limiter
frame synchronization image sharpening
adaptive tessellation as I say not that
much there but probably more to come
display options quite useful if you want
to like tweak around different monitor
settings and things you can do that you
can turn on your variable refresh rate
it's annoying that you can't actually
choose to like select a high quality
resolution or something like you can in
the Nvidia control panel or now Nvidia
app but definitely not the end of the
world but you can do most stuff here and
you can see you've got your full screen
full screen and windowed or disabled for
your variable refresh there and then we
also have a performance tab that's going
to be great for overclocking and
obviously monitoring your FPS and things
so again very similar to what you have
with AMD and Nvidia as long as it works
great we didn't really have this at all
in the original version certainly at
launch and what we did have didn't
really work that well so again nice to
have it here but I would definitely like
there to be more it's kind of quite
lightweight really compared to what you
can get with Nvidia and AMD but do most
people use those features probably not
but definitely it'd be good if there was
like a record and stream setting here
because that's definitely missing and
that's definitely quite frustrating but
you know what I think the time for talk
is well and truly over how about we
actually see what this thing is like in
the bit that matters the games and in
order to kick this off we are actually
going to start this with some Dragon Age
Inquisition oh dear no I had such high
hopes I had such high hopes I was about
to do this big enthusiastic intro about
how we're going to jump into some games
and we've got Dragon Age The Veil guard
but I mean look we have texture
flickering things are not working
properly I really thought this time
would be different maybe we're just so
unlucky that there's one game that just
doesn't work properly with this GPU
maybe it's cuz we're recording with OBS
there's so many reasons this could be
and it could get fixed but so far we put
this car in it doesn't have the features
that I want and as soon as we jump into
a game we've got all of this horrible
flickering I said this needed to be
seamless this needed to be a slam dunk
but if you get your favorite game I mean
this isn't even that new at this point
it has been out for what a month month
and a half and you fire up your brand
new graphics card that you've paid £250
a for and you get this you are going to
be very very disappointed I mean I think
you can hear that in my voice because as
I say it's it's a problem I'm sure it
can get fixed but it shouldn't be a
problem I can't remember the last time I
fired up a new AMD or Nvidia graphics
card and saw anything like this so what
are the chances that the very first game
that I fire up we have these sorts of
issues this is such a shame I mean
otherwise the frame rate was good at
around about 75 FPS or so right this was
actually running at Ultra as well we can
turn raay tracing on we'll try that
maybe that will fix it what is the raay
tracing performance of this card like
well that's not really done anything at
all has it I mean the frame rate's good
clearly this is a capable card when it
comes to to RT but look at that do I
need to say anymore I mean I guess we
can try closing OBS no that hasn't fixed
it should we get rid of After Burner is
that causing our problems no I think
Veil guard's out honestly Intel please
come on we need this let that be a
oneoff let's move on now to our next
title from Ghost of shishima no what's
this this is the exact same settings and
game we had the other day no what's
going on this was supposed to work no
you know what would be the irony if the
driver hadn't installed properly and
because it hadn't told us that was
causing all of these problems anyway
let's get this recording so you can
actually see what's going on now have a
look at that frame time graph this is
just horrible stutter like this this is
unplayable at the moment because while
the frame rate is still around about 60
65 FPS uh is just a Judy mess I really
don't know what the solution is because
clearly something isn't working properly
so maybe we need to clean install
Windows we need to get rid of any like
existing drivers and things although we
do need the driver for the CPU so that
actually probably would be detrimental
and it's just not realistic because
again we don't need to do those sorts of
things for new Nvidia cards for new AMD
cards so even if there is like a
relatively easy fix for these things the
average consumer that's going to be
buying one of these cards is not going
to be able or at least want to have to
deal with these issues and so far that's
two out of two that just don't work
properly that is so frustrating and I
don't really understand why we've got
more vram so it shouldn't be like a vram
issue I'm so glad I recorded this this
is what I mean you need to know about
the experience there's no good me just
telling you about it you see my mood go
from wow this is actually going to be
really good
to ah something went wrong with this
game I guess maybe third times is the
charm really needs to work now doesn't
it this is an older game surely what we
have here is of course some Apex Legends
this is running at the high preset looks
great on this monitor actually and so
far seems to be working as intended I
mean r about 180 FPS this will increase
a bit I'm sure as we actually hit the
ground actually it stayed roughly about
the same I mean this is actually quite
an intense area of the city or so but
yeah it's this is now working as
intended which I don't know if I'm happy
about or sad about because I was
thinking well if I just ddu the driver
start again get rid of everything then
maybe that will fix the issues cuz they
were so obviously wrong but the fact
that this seems to be working in a way
is kind of a little bit more concerning
because some games and hopefully most
games will just work but then you might
get others that don't and that was the
problem we had with Ark originally and
that was the reason we weren't
recommending Ark so I don't know but as
you can see it's nice and smooth we're
getting around about 5 milliseconds or
so that frame time graph is really
pretty good actually it should be as
flat as possible there's a couple of
Peaks but don't forget this is like
really really low latency so it's kind
of like any change will show up on that
we're not getting any large spikes like
we saw before so okay I'm more satisfied
now this is a good gaming experience 160
FPS dx12 mode great looking title and is
running very well but this is what
people want £250 $250 if you could get
around about 200 FPS let's say at
1440p that's all the GPU that you need
if we started with this I'd be saying
very different things but yeah slightly
concerning isn't it but it could just be
me could just be this system could be
the setup but again this is real world
this is what people are going to do so
over to future benchmarkers oh hello
everyone benchmarkers here and I've got
to be honest it's once again been an
absolute week of Intel chaos I mean it's
better than Ultra but not exactly night
and day because after a week of testing
I'm still not exactly 100% clear on
where I stand now it could be construed
as a very impressive card for the price
yet it's also the biggest hassle of any
GPU launched since the original Arc in
my opinion but let's start with a good
when it works it works really rather
well with cyber Punk clearly showing
huge gains versus Team Green and frankly
a laughing stock versus the radon 7600
do bear in mind though that these gains
do reduce down as the resolution drops
which is kind of annoying as you're more
likely to be playing at 1080p than 4K
now rate tracing was disabled in those
numbers so moving on to our rate Trace
testing i instead opted for returnal as
it's a great implementation and one
that's easier to run and again this is
fantastic news for Arc well if you
ignore the unsupported GPU warning that
flashes up on first boot but otherwise
it's a clear win for team blue with
decent frame rates across the board
though the margins here are definitely
reduced when it comes to the minimums
once again AMD is looking pretty weak
here presenting an unplayable experience
of 1440p whereas Intel plus variable
refresh rate would actually be viable
but let's be honest you'd probably
rather aim for 60 FPS with rt disabled
so if does any of this even matter and
that ladies and gentlemen is the end of
the good news as we press on to the bad
and ultimately the reason reason why I'm
not recommending one of these art cards
just yet issues driver issues and
missing features let's start with Planet
coaster 2 and initially I thought I'd
just chosen settings that were too high
for this level of gaming but nope this
is just clearly a badly performing game
on Intel and I mean to put this into
proper perspective we saw a similar fps
to the almost 5-year-old RTX 2060 not
good and unless you were going to be
playing at 108p medium you'd probably be
very disappointed especially when you
paid $250 for the privilege and you know
that there is more in this card it's
just bad drivers that are holding it
back and unfortunately the same can also
be said for CS2 though the argument
could be made that it's less of an issue
as the FPS is already plentiful though
I'd argue that you want to get what you
pay for and not full short I mean we're
roughly losing 100 FPS at 1440p and
almost 200 FPS at full HD but please sir
can I have some more or also add in that
I did rerun the art card by the way with
a newer driver supplied a few days after
the initial tests and I saw the exact
same numbers though the issues with both
Dragon Age and ghosts have thankfully
been resolved but the fact that they
were there in the first place is pretty
telling to me I said that in order for
this to be a card for truly everyone
Intel needs to have a Flawless launch
and this is anything but really it's
better than ark1 but it's just not on
par with AMD on Nvidia for the it just
works Factor so ultimately I would say
if you need to buy something right now
I'd go for the RTX 4060 and take the
lower FPS or just wait wait a few months
see if the drive is mature see if
there's going to be an RTX 5060 that
will be even better or hey wait for both
to happen and then you might get price
drop from Intel and then you can go for
that so sure in a load of games this may
well be fantastic but based on my
testing based on my issues I've got to
say that I'm pretty disappointed that I
didn't get what I wanted a carard that
is just better than Nvidia rather than
another sequel of it can be better than
Nvidia when it works I just find the
whole thing pretty frustrating and
pretty confusing in a way because I
really want Intel to succeed I think
everyone does really because more
competition is always a good thing but
from Intel side of things and I actually
had a long chat with them yesterday some
of the Big Wigs they are trying as hard
as they can they're going through
they've got teams doing like the top 90%
if you like of all of the games that are
played and they're really trying to make
sure that every driver is going to work
properly they say it was essentially
just like a braning issue which is why a
lot of the problems that I had with
things like Dragon Age and ghosts made
it into the Press driver but we're never
going to make it into the final driver
but the fact remains that all of the
time that Intel kind of having to just
optimize every single title almost more
than both AMD and Nvidia have to because
obviously the developers are kind of
developing for the masses which is
mainly Nvidia also AMD and relatively
speaking not that many people have an
art card so if you're already kind of
like tied for resources why you going to
optimize for like a tiny amount of
people when you still need to optimize
for the majority of people so I get it
that it is pretty difficult for Intel
but the fact remains that I'm am not
here to sell you graphics cards I'm here
to tell you the truth and the truth is
that while the performance of this card
can be fantastic and I genuinely do
think that this card as the older ones
did are going to start to come in their
own if you are someone that doesn't want
to mess around with PC gaming you just
want it to work then nothing really has
changed you still need to buy an AMD or
an Nvidia graphics card but compared to
the original launch of the original Arc
I am satisfied that this is a lot better
it just needs to be even better than
that to wholeheartedly recommend to
everyone so if you are still a little
bit of a tweaker you're happy maybe to
wait a couple of months or so for your
favorite games to get optimized you
don't always buy everything day one then
I would definitely consider it but I
think even if you are in this Camp it's
worth just waiting an extra couple of
months two or three just to kind of see
what happens with the drivers and
whether this is a story that improves
which would be fantastic or stays the
same or could even be worse we don't
know this is not a day one purchase but
it is something that you should strongly
consider and even if you're never going
to buy this then just be thankful that
Intel are offering something that is
going to make both AMD and Nvidia triple
think shall we say before they release
something and who knows maybe the
resulting RTX 5060 will have a slightly
lower price because of Intel so if that
is the minimum that we get from this
launch fantastic but hopefully the
maximum is as I say in a few months time
this is really easy to recommend and we
don't have any more issues but until
that day comes watch this space if
you've enjoyed this video then please
smash the like button it really helps
out and of course get subscribe for more
videos just like this including a full
Intel build that's actually coming
tomorrow that's a pretty fun one and of
course if you do want to check out
current pricing on this GPU or anything
that we used in this video as always you
can find it linked down below with our
affiliate links and while you're down
there why not indulge yourself in the
power of the gigabyte g6x this stunning
gaming laptop hits The Sweet Spot of
luxury look and feel combined with
Powerhouse gaming performance and
immersive Dolby Atmos audio its
beautiful display has an incredible 90%
screen to body ratio and the RTX 4060
laptop GPU not only brings jawdropping
frame rates but also accelerates AI
applications with a mighty 233 tops of
processing power level up your
Battlefield today with the gigabyte g6x
learn more with the link down below
thank you guys so much for watching
we'll catch you in the next one
a
[Music]